I'm a lesbian, but I used to date men
and there's a lot in the media at the moment
about violence against women
and the man or the bear in the woods scenario.
And I've got a story that I think is really applicable to it,
although I never thought I would tell it on social media.
Back when I was a young pup,
I was on Tinder and I match with this fella.
It was very, very early Covid.
We agreed to catch up. He drove to me
and we were just gonna go out and get coffee
and sit somewhere and drink it.
I was always someone that would like to go out in public,
but Covid didn't allow us to do that.
He then drove to where I lived.
I met up with him and we met in a car park
and I asked him to jump in my car.
He drove a 79 series cruiser and I drove a Ranger.
And he, it was like, oh,
I'm a chippy and I've got tools in my car.
Like I really can't, I can't leave this here.
Can we take mine? And based on like the situation with the tools,
I was like, oh,
you know what, that's probably fair.
That's alright. We'll go in your car.
So I jumped in his car. We went and got coffee
and we headed out to this like quiet sort of lookout area.
We were just having a conversation.
It was Alright,
everything was good and then suddenly within like half an hour,
he's like, alright,
well, are we gonna do this or what?
Oh, it's hot.
I remember looking at him being like, what?
And he was like, well,
this is why we're here, isn't it?
And I was like, no,
like we're just going on a date.
And I remember him just being like,
no, that's not why we're here.
And he got quite tense and I was like shit.
I was like, I'm out in the middle of nowhere and this guy's car,
he wants to do something, I don't wanna do it.
What am I gonna do?
I remember explicitly thinking about the things that could happen
and there was five different things that could happen.
Number one, I say I'm not interested and he goes,
yep, all good,
no worries
and we either continue talking or he takes me back to my car.
No. 2, I say no and he does it anyway.
No.3, I say no and he bashes the shit out of me or worse,
No. 4, I say no,
he leaves me on the side of the road.
Or No. 5, I just do it and I go home and I feel like shit about myself.
Those are my five options.
Now out of those five options,
only two of those outcomes that I like
thought were relatively favorable.
One was that he accepted it and took me home
and two is
That he left me on the side of the road in the middle of nowhere
the other parties I Learned early
if you just do what they want you to do
you go home and you feel like absolute shit about yourself
and then you have to wear that that's on you
they walk away feeling freaking great
and you go home feeling like shit however
most women would still rather go through that
then get the absolute shit fucking beaten out of them
or potentially even worse
or be forced to do it at least if we are complicit
we at least get to go home and say well
I wanted it
I chose to do it I don't know what I was thinking that night
but I was like nah
fuck yeah I'm not doing it and I said no
and he he cracked the sheets and he left me on the side of the road
and the fact that I got left on the side of the road
in the middle of nowhere and I was like man
I got lucky in this situation is absolutely disgusting
there's a few things that I've Learned from this story is No. 1
every time I've told this story to a girl
they've got extremely similar situation
but nine times out of 10 they just did it they didn't say no
and the second part of the story is
I'm actually being scared
that telling this story to people is Actually
not interesting enough because it's so common.
It's something that happens to everyone.
That's not interesting enough
or it's not significant enough to talk about to other people
because everyone has seen worse,
which is, again,
horrifying fact
that most women would choose to be left alone in the woods
with a bear over a man in 2024
when we are such a developed species is actually fucked up.
I'm not gay because of my negative experiences with men.
But I tell you what,
it's really nice not having to worry about them as much.